You live in Spain
or you know someone who is living in Spain
and that at this time
is in financial straits,
who has no job,
that the money he gets is not enough
for food
for his family.
You should know that in Spain
there are NGOs that can help you with food,
you have documentation or no documentation.
This NGO is going to be a solution.
It's called fesval,
Spanish Federation of Food Banks
and you may ask,
and where is it located?
What is your main headquarters?
Well,
I tell you that this NGO
has 54 food banks throughout Spain
and fesval
is supported by more than 7,000 charities
in Spanish territory.
And it is that fesval
eh has the support
of large supermarket chains
and companies that make donations
to fight hunger.
Main page,
there is an option
who claims to look for the nearest food bank.
Then you will get this page
and sliding up
you will find a map where you can identify which one
is much closer to you.
If there really weren't any near where you live,
they are going to refer to another NGO that is nearby.
to get food help to you.
And now,
how do I register?
You enter the home page,
triple w fesval point r g point es.
You are going to locate the office closest to where you live.
and you are going to communicate by phone,
by e-mail,
to be able to speak directly to it.
They are going to say No,
but I call and they never answer.
Do we have to persist
because they always have a lot of people eh?
That he is in need of this assistance.
Then we must try to communicate,
call, call,
call.
They are going to ask for a number of requirements,
some very basic documents
to know where you live,
evaluate your situation
and if necessary.
And if they see that you are a person they need,
will offer you eh
already as an appointment where you come to pick up the food.
And hey,
I hope you will share this information
with people who really need it
because there are many people who do not need it
and requests assistance.
Not to be left
aid for people in need.
If in my case it is not necessary to apply for help,
why should I ask for it?
So you know,
fesval